[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we're here
at the rooftop of the dream hotel in
Hollywood and it's a pretty dreamy
little day here we're catching up with
the ladies of bachelor nation at soul
society's Fall collection launch what
did you think of Rachel's finale okay
I'm gonna be honest I think I was just
as like Geron and shocked as everyone
else and just like into it the break of
a theater was super intense but the
finale she looks super beautiful and so
happy so I'm happy for them do you see
Peter being a bachelor I think so I
think people are really excited for
Peter I think that he handled himself
very well very gracefully and
respectfully how much has your
relationship changed since your finale
so much so much been a little over a
year since our finale and I look back
and our relationship has grown into
something so much stronger and more
beautiful than I think we even expected
to happen and it's just awesome like we
we get each other our relationship is
good I'm really happy I think right
after you go through hard times and and
it's not easy to transition into normal
life that quickly and so I know that I'm
not the first we had a hard time Rachel
and Brian will have ours and Kaitlyn and
Shawn you all go through these these
situations where you're like trying to
figure it out you're able to get through
it it turns into something very
beautiful
I asked Rachel um Brian how are you guys
gonna get through it what advice do you
have for them once the show ends you're
gonna be so overwhelmed with so much
love and so much support because this
the bachelor nation fan base that
falling is on like unbelievable how
supportive they are but you're always
gonna have the negative the negative
opinions and in the hurtful comments and
I think if you just focus on your
relationship not let it get to you it's
going to get to you but not let it get
you the point to where you start taking
it out on each other and if you're able
to get through that then I think that
your relationship proves itself
you
[Music]